OUR J.P. MAROZZI IS WITH ALL
THREE HUGHES BROTHERS.
J.P.: QUINN, LUKE AND JACK.
LUKE, WE TALKED THREE YEARS AGO.
THE DREAM OF PLAYING WITH ONE OF
OUR BROTHERS IN THE NHL, WHAT IS
THE REALITY?
LUKE: I'M SUPER EXCITED TO PLAY
WITH JACK AND SOME DAY HOPEFULLY
WITH QUINN, TOO.
I'M SUPER EXCITED TO BE A DEVIL.
J.P.: YOUR GRANDMOTHER SAID
SHE'D NEVER SEEN YOU SO HAPPY.
JACK, WHAT DID YOU FEEL WHEN YOU
HEARD THAT ANNOUNCEMENT?
JACK: AWESOME.
A GREAT PICK FOR OUR TEAM AND
I'M A PROUD OLDER BROTHER RIGHT
NOW.
J.P.: TAKE ME INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
AFTER THE DUCKS MADE THEIR PICK,
WHAT WERE YOU SAYING TO EACH
OTHER HERE?
>> I JUST THINK WE WEREN'T SURE
IF HE WAS GOING THERE OR NOT.
EVERYONE WANTED HIM TO GO THERE.
I WAS KIND OF TELLING HIM, IF
YOU DON'T GO THERE, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT IT.
THE RINK STINKS ANYWAYS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND OF COURSE THINKING I
REALLY WANT HIM TO GO THERE BUT
LIKE JACK SAID, I THINK THEY
MADE A GREAT PICK FOR THE TEAM.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO REALLY
HELP THEM AND THEN, OF COURSE,
THE BROTHER DYNAMIC.
I'M A LITTLE JEALOUS, BUT SUPER
EXCITED FOR THEM.
REALLY COOL, REALLY SPECIAL.
J.P.: LUKE, YOU'VE WORN THE SAME
NUMBER AS YOUR BROTHERS AT THE
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
NOW YOU'RE WEARING ONE OF JACK'S
JERSEYS.
WHAT DID THAT MEAN?
LUKE: IT'S A DREAM COME TRUE.
I'M SO EXCITED ANDREA -- AND
REALLY HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
J.P.: WE COULD HAVE FIRST GAME
OF THE NEXT SEASON IN THE
CUL-DE-SAC HERE.
>> I DON'T THINK I COULD TAKE
BOTH OF THEM.
I THINK AS A FAMILY WE'RE JUST
EXTREMELY HAPPY FOR HIM AND
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE PLAYING
TOGETHER THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO,
VERY SPECIAL.
J.P.: JACK, TO KNOW YOUR PARENTS
GOING COAST TO COAST NOW AT
LEAST HAVING TWO TEAMS TO
FOLLOW.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
>> IT WILL MAKE LIFE EASIER FOR
SURE.
THEY WON'T HAVE TO FLY TO A
THIRD CITY.
THAT WILL BE NICE.
WE NEED TO GET A THIRD ROOM FOR
ANOTHER ROOMMATE.
I'M PUMPED TO HAVE LUKE.
A GREAT PICK.
J.P.: MORE THAN 11,000 DRAFT
PICKS IN THE HISTORY OF THE NHL.
FIRST TIME EVER THREE BROTHERS
HAVING GONE IN THE TOP 10.
QUINN, YOUR THOUGHTS?
QUINN: SUPER SPECIAL.
GREAT LEAGUE AND GREAT TALENT
HAS COME THROUGH.
I THINK YOU REALLY HAVE TO LOOK
AT OUR PARENTS.
IT'S TOO HARD TO DO.
WE'RE 66'6" -- I THINK THEY
REALLY HAD TO TEACH US THE GAME.
EXTREMELY HARD AND A LOT OF
CREDIT TO THEM.
J.P.: FOUR OF THE TOP FIVE PICKS
THIS COMING SEASON.
LUKE: I'M SUPER EXCITED FOR
MICHIGAN.
J.P.: WHAT A GREAT NIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS,